good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I had
a pretty big week last week my novel The
Fault in Our Stars returned to number
one on the New York Times bestseller
list 56 weeks after it came out also my
wife and I are expecting our second
child whom the President of the United
States told not to forget to be awesome
but most importantly a for the first
time in American history a sitting
president of the United States
acknowledged that pennies are a terrible
idea he also acknowledged the penny as
an excellent metaphor for what's wrong
with governance so yes it was an
incredible weekend in the wake of
incredible weeks what I usually do is
crawl into bed I don't know why this is
Hank but it's been happening my whole
life I just get overwhelmed with anxiety
and I decide that I should crawl into
bed and never do anything ever again but
that is a bad life strategy Hank so
today I'm going to update you on 12
things that we are doing one Mental
Floss ten people haven't asked me how to
get started as a writer my advice is
always to find people who are also
starting out and work with them my first
writing gig ever in my life was with
Mental Floss ten years later I talked
into a camera for living and they've
gone on to become this educational and
trivia Empire but they've never had a
YouTube channel until now thank you and
I are both working on this and I'm
really excited to bring Mental Floss to
YouTube there's going to be list videos
and quizzes and like a cool intro it's
gonna be great thing to the project for
awesome so we still haven't announced
which charities are getting the money
but that's because we don't know how
much money there is going to be and
probably won't know for a couple more
weeks because we have to work with
PayPal and figure out how much shipping
costs and various other things sing
three The Fault in Our Stars movie I'm
not gonna lie to you I've had my heart
broken by Hollywood before but I'm
starting to think that The Fault in Our
Stars movie is actually going to be a
thing so yeah that's it please don't
believe everything that you read on the
internet because journalists who work in
Los Angeles seem to just make things up
rest assured that when there is news it
will not come from like celeb gossip
buzz it will come from me thing forward
dftba records having taken over an
abandoned nursery school in Missoula
Montana dftba records is bigger and more
awesome than ever we're continuing to
try to make dftba more and more about
getting cool stuff that also supports
people you like whether that's a CGP
grey coffee mug or a wheezywaiter
t-shirt or a poster partly designed by a
16 year old Norwegian girl named a seal
number 5 my writing
um drawing number 6 the Swindon Town
skoodilypooping the last FIFA 11 Swindon
Town spooly poopers video goes up
tomorrow
when we will find out if we win the
Barclays Premier League and if the
miracle of Swindon Town is complete I
just want to go out a winner for the
boys by the way I think the actual
Swindon Town Football Club is currently
looking for a manager and I just want to
state for the record I am available
number 7 crash course Hank you just
started teaching chemistry which sounds
very unpromising and yet it has been
really entertaining and interesting and
I am kind of learning meanwhile I'm
three episodes into teaching the history
of Canada's pants also known as the
United States of America number 8 VidCon
2013 Hank most of the tickets to VidCon
2013 are gone so if people want one they
should get one now VidCon is gonna be
really fun this year it will also be the
first time that I leave the house after
the birth of my kids so I will be ready
to party and by party I mean sleep for
eight hours in a row you know what I'm
talking about parents number nine the
Lizzie Bennet diaries Hank I get several
emails a day complimenting me on my
excellent work for the Lizzie Bennet
diaries which I don't do I am NOT
involved with that project at all
however I am happy to take credit for it
number 10 the kiva.org nerdfighters Hank
the nerdfighters of Kiva are approaching
two million dollars in loans to
entrepreneurs in the developing world
number eleven parenting is still my
biggest job at the moment and number 12
- Dee glasses which render
three-dimensional movies in a crisp two
dimensions Hank this idea that you had
for 2d glasses which I thought was a
terrible idea
turns out to have been brilliant the 2d
glasses empire grows by the day Hank you
have way too many ideas but thank you
for having them because they pull me out
of the quicksand of myself and forced me
to get to work dftba
I will see you on Friday